There are few franchises that have been churning
out movies semi-regularly since the early
1960s.
Even fewer have brought the kind of box office
results that break records.
And there's really only one named after a
character so suave that grown men immediately
feel an overwhelming desire to imitate him
when they put on a tuxedo.
When it comes to these criteria, no one does
it better than...
“Bond, James Bond."
Sean Connery was the original "official" James
Bond, bringing the character from the pages
of intelligence-officer-turned-writer Ian
Fleming's novels to the big screen.
His first adventure was 1962's Dr. No, which
cost $1 million to make and earned nearly
$60 million worldwide (a little over $509
million in 2020 money).
The role brought Connery fame, fortune, and
an eternal association with an iconic character.
But the famously brash and borderline reclusive
Connery - who passed away at the age of 90
in October, 2020 - wasn't just a member of
the exclusive list of actors who've played
Bond.
He also has a metaphorical membership to the
club of actors who regret the role that made
them famous.
This is the reason Sean Connery regretted
playing James Bond.
Connery was lucky to land the role of Bond.
According to the late Richard Maibaum , known
for his screenplay adaptations of the Bond
novels,
"[Fleming] thought David Niven would have
made a great James Bond."
Roger Moore was also considered for the part
early on.
Connery's bad-boy vibe ultimately won him
the part, but the success of Dr. No quickly
turned his big break into an all-encompassing
headache.
Connery was dismissive of the Bond films while
he was still making them.
In 1964 - when his third Bond outing, Goldfinger,
was in production - Connery told an interviewer
that Bond was just "a dull, prosaic English
policeman" when all the "exotic touches" were
removed.
He could have been demonstrating unique modesty,
but it certainly sounds like he didn't think
very highly of Bond.
In November 1965, Connery admitted to a reporter
that he was already "fed up to here with the
whole Bond bit."
Though Connery said at the time that he "shouldn't
knock" Bond - and said in a November 1964
interview with The New York Times that he'd
be "everlastingly grateful" to the character
- his attitude changed over the years.
By the time he was shooting You Only Live
Twice, released in 1967, Connery had fallen
out with producer Albert "Cubby" Broccoli,
who'd been instrumental in getting him hired.
It didn't help that he was stalked and chased
by paparazzi during filming, or that he felt
his salary was too low.
You Only Live Twice was meant to be Connery's
last Bond appearance, but he returned for
1971's Diamonds Are Forever - though not out
of love for the character.
In a 1971 interview with The Guardian, Connery
made it clear that he resented the studio
executives for wasting his time.
"I'd been [messed] about too much on other
Bond pictures.
There's so much bulls--- that comes from bad
decisions being made at the top."
Connery struck a deal to be paid $10,000 per
week if the film's shoot ran over the scheduled
18 weeks.
He added,
"Talking to some of these moguls about it
is like trying to describe to someone who
has never taken exercise what it is like to
feel fit when you do exercise.
They don't understand."
Apparently, Connery only agreed to make the
movie (having skipped 1969's On Her Majesty's
Secret Service) because he was given a large
percentage of profits and the opportunity
to produce two movies of his choice.
And Connery wasn't done with Bond money yet:
He returned for the appropriately titled Never
Say Never Again, reportedly for around $5
million.
Amidst all of that, Connery made it clear
how he really felt about the character that
launched his career, via The Guardian:
"I have always hated that damned James Bond.
I'd like to kill him."
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stars are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.